you guys did a lot of great podcasts
together he asked you in a very
uncomfortable process of why you don't
do stand-up so let me ask you
do you hate money
well I'm originally from Canada yeah so
I'm uh I'm yeah I'm I'm a freaking Pinko
uh socialist is that what uh where you
come from that's not a nice thing to say
I thought the Soviet Union that is a
nice thing to say like I call someone
right comrade yeah he's a he's a good
he's a good socialist yeah he has red
like some bold colors yeah yeah there
was an interesting tension in your voice
and the way you talked about it there's
just not a source of happiness for you
you you respect the art form but it was
not something that you were connected to
you felt connected to that's a good way
to put it yeah I I respect the art form
uh a lot I and I grew up with all the
albums and stuff I had an older brother
and sister who so I you know we had the
we had George Carlin we had uh you know
Richard Pryor we had Robert Klein we had
Guild alive the Gilda Radner uh concert
we had we had all sorts of stuff but you
know I don't know there's a lot of
there's a lot of reasons I do feel like
a career in Show Business
it is you know they it never goes the
way you plan uh like most things and I
was fortunate enough to get started
outside of my native Vancouver or in my
native Vancouver I grew up in The Burbs
outside and there was a lot of Industry
there so I was fortunate enough to get
started as an actor when I was like 16
so
there there yeah there was there were
some times early on where I came up with
some stand-up stuff and did it but uh
yeah I quickly abandoned it and then
you know you go through you do Mad TV
and stuff and then and that's where my
and this is going to sound weird do I
sound as anxietal as I did when I was on
Bobby's podcast trying to avoid his
questions
well he was giving you this face this
whole time that was making
the whole just atmosphere feel full of
anxiety so I'm trying not to give you
the face um the whole time I was saying
play cool play cool yeah okay uh play
collects play cool you said it out loud
a couple times I did just you know you
cut that out okay cool play cool dude
cut out cut it out maintain bro here's
what I'll say there's two ways to do it
I think it's lame when someone who's
done one thing for a while goes and
starts doing stand-up out of nowhere
because I think it's an art form that's
uh
under attack because it's not like
anything else you need although now you
can of course
you know make whatever you want it's the
era of self-publishing as far as making
a product and putting it out there which
is getting easier of course and I can't
wait to talk to you about that with with
AI and how it's changing art
um but uh the in stand up all you need
is a is a microphone and you know
perhaps uh it'd be good to have some
mental illness and then you can just run
up there and uh uh talk forever and I
say this to to you know comedians it's
like you guys have to deal with Justin
influx of
people who aren't sure why they're doing
comedy I would ask community in Zoom
like I mean not good ones and good ones
you know what they're doing but everyone
else like what are you doing why why are
you doing stand-up having said that I am
allergic to money yeah do you think they
have a good answer for that why are they
doing it because I actually like when
I'm in Austin I like going to open mics
just listening it's inspiring to me
both the funny and the unfunny people
because they've been doing it for
several years
sometimes over a decade yeah and they're
still at it they're still right there
there's going for the punch and then
especially open mics that are really sad
in that there is you know only like five
other people in the audience and they're
usually just other Comedians and they're
still going all out as if they're in
front of a stadium but that to me sounds
like someone who loves it yeah I got no
questions for that person I got
questions for someone who goes sideways
from here I'm recognizable doing
something and then I'm doing stand-up
because it's like and truly look I've
been I've been fortunate enough to be in
the business for a long time and at this
point if I came up I mean doing live
stuff is fun I have friends that are
like um you know some guys who are
primarily sketch people or you would
look at them as sketch people and they
can sell tickets for being sketch people
and they and we'll talk about it and
they're like well you know I do a
monologue I do a little stand up then I
do a song then I do another monologue
then I play off the audience do a little
stand-up
um but stand up is it's almost like
playing music in that
you know people are going up there
playing music but what band have you
been listening to that's what you're
going to sound like
so it's really I mean of course I'm
speaking from zero experience but I've
heard it takes years of course to find
your own voice stand-ups that when they
first go up they're they're doing a some
sort of impersonation of so and so right
and so and so you got to pop this
audience that that's paying and you're
going to get run over by the next person
who's coming up and uh it's hard to
follow the last person who went up
before you and I said I mean that is a
really hard way to it's a very
quite a gauntlet to be in to find your
voice comedically but don't you have
that same kind of thing with Sketch you
still have to find your own voice with
uh like all the Impressions you do
they're just terrible you know they're
they're different spins and different
people they're not like perfect
Impressions right yeah so that's I mean
that's a similar kind of Challenge and
journey yeah as stand up you're just
saying they're kind of distinct and you
fell into this one you fell in love with
it which is like what Mad TV kind of
opened you up to yeah as a kid I
literally wanted to be an actor I always
wanted to be an actor from a very young
age as far back as I can remember and I
was a Class Clown and wanted to do
comedy stuff and comedic acting and
music acting yeah early on my my
influences were a very predictable list
of uh guys from from the SCTV early
Saturday Night Live uh Monty Python all
of those performers really influenced me
it was later that I saw
people like Kevin Kline who's an
incredible actor I vividly remember
being like 12 13 seeing him get an
Academy Award for A Fish Called Wanda
and it blew my mind because I was like
he was hilarious I mean it was one of my
favorite movies back then and now and uh
he won an Academy Award and at that
point I I started thinking more about
acting and then I was like I said really
fortunate to fall in with um I mean I
always wanted to do it and I was trying
to hustle this and that when I was a kid
and then I ended up getting represented
and then I I ended up on a teen show I
was on I basically the easiest way to
pitch it is it's like a Canadian my
so-called life with these kids in their
lives and stuff and I did that for like
five years and
I really love acting I really truly love
acting and I don't
I'm not someone who wants people to know
my opinion
so that's another thing about stand up
like I love The Illusion of what I get
to do in uh in uh entertainment and
podcasting is great for that but to
stand up there and
from I don't know just for me it's like
it would have to all be fantasy